all right joining me now is chris
bedford founding partner of right forge
chris now given the stakes uh the teeth
gnashing over the gop candidates
to me is maddening it takes an enormous
amount of courage
an enormous amount of resolve to get
into politics in this day and age as a
republican running as an america first
republican your reaction and we all know
why mitch mcconnell was so down on them
is because he didn't get to hand pick
them these aren't just the career
politicians or the or the businessman
trying to put a political cap on their
careers that he prefers people who are
just going to be on the line with him on
judges and taxes and never get out of
line he can't control them she doesn't
really like them he should be out there
talking about how fetterman is is is
nearly crippled by the stroke he's
having difficulty talking he's been
hiding for weeks and weeks and weeks he
should be out there saying that this
guy's a cosplayer just up in a
sweatshirt but he's never worked in a
steel mill once in his life he actually
looks more like the kid playing video
games in his parents basement he could
be talking about how mark kelly's got
zero personality how warnock is a
radical but instead he wants to go after
these candidates because he wasn't in
charge if he got to choose them the
voters ended up choosing them and he's
angry over that well everyone has to
remember that he didn't want rand paul
in the u.s senate
he grudgingly had to go along with that
but he was against rand paul
mitch mcconnell has always done whatever
mitch mcconnell wants to do whether it
was a tea party movement where he would
just say tea party while doing what
mcconnell wanted to do or during trump's
administration when he would yell maga
while doing exactly what mitch mcconnell
wanted to do he's in charge but one of
the ways to break that is to get outside
money in that mitch mcconnell was
someone who blake masters who pushed
back a lot against mitch mcconnell had
to go and kind of apologize to almost
and speak kindly of because mcconnell
controls so much money where are all the
donations that are going to president
trump he should be using that money to
help be a king maker not just in the
rallies but helping to support these
candidates i agree so they don't need
mcconnell's trump trump's got to pony up
money in these races i 100 agree we lost
those senate seats in georgia i think
that was really bad i don't think we
needed to lose those
i think that money's got to flow great
point now chris speaking of fetterman i
want to play more of this um
blisteringly long five-minute speech he
gave today in front of the props that
were his steel workers watch
what is wrong with demanding for
an easy
safe
kind of
their
income
a path to a
safe place for them to win
or excuse me to work
and make sure that we deliver what we
need to to make sure we
deliver
an advocate for the sacred union way of
life
chris there's obviously something wrong
with fetterman and we can't let our
compassion for him get in the way of
what's at stake here in this race
they're playing all the games on the
crudite and you know the fact that oz
has lived in new jersey but
that's all they have they have stunts
and gimmicks because that man
shouldn't be running for the senate and
he cannot be elected to the senate
because he doesn't represent
pennsylvania values and and oz needs to
show some courage here and he needs to
go outside of the box he needs to follow
some of the campaign trail ideas that
donald trump gave us of basically acting
less like a politician and more like a
wrestler go over to fetterman's house
bang on his door say come out and debate
me why don't we have a conversation the
guy inside there he can barely string
together a sentence you want to send him
to the u.s senate come out and speak to
me instead oz wants to release these
videos fine he i think oz would be a
better senator obviously federerman's
record would put him exactly in line
with whatever the joe biden and the
democrats wanted they're no longer a
populist party but oz needs to step up
and challenge him and call him out in
the things that you're saying right now
you know i think
we we have to deal with the soldiers on
the field that we have these are the
political soldiers we have it's in some
cases it wasn't the army we wanted but
this is the battle ahead of us and
republicans who are throwing you know
shade on these on these candidates i
have no words for them and they're not
words i could say on today and
mcconnell's shoveling money to murkowski
no problem the voters in our state don't
even want the republican voters he has
no issue putting money toward that he
doesn't want to help out these guys we
need not only mcconnell to step up but
also president trump and the other
populists to step up with the money that
they have to push this herschel walker
oz masters we're going to talk to in a
few moments all of these people all
these people running deserve enormous
amount of respect for being in the ring
you know i i'm not running i'm
they're running and their first time and
it's really hard and i think i think
they'll be fantastic to get in the
senate but i like your advice all right
chris great to see you in studio hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else